[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
there's a conspiracy the last hope is
okay let's do a some another zika ebola
operation where um
uh we scare everybody
you know apparently 20 000 to 50 000
people a year die from the flu so
there's people dying all the time of the
flu but you never hear about it but if
you take this human coronavirus which is
on the back of lysol if you look at the
back of a lysol
spray can it says it lists all the
viruses that it kills and it says human
coronavirus and it uh so it's not like
it's new it's just like the technical
name for a kind of flu flu is like
there's a bunch of different strains of
flu and they have a bunch of different
names so
one theory is
this is just a psyop to [ __ ] the economy
up and that it's working if that's what
it is it's working because the stocks uh
i don't know anything about stocks but
apparently they tumbled and like the
economy is like getting taken a big hit
so that's a theory that it's all just an
operation just like zika just like ebola
you know and then one person died in the
united states and everybody's freaking
out 50 000 people a year die from the
flu so you know i mean six people a year
die from like coconuts falling on their
head or something like that so one
person died in washington and as an old
lady i don't know i don't know what to
believe i have no idea so then the
question becomes
is it possible that we can alter that is
it possible that we can alter that with
the communication that we have today
with all the knowledge that we've
gathered up maybe our ideas of things
being natural unnatural or are archaic
maybe we're going to be able to reason
through that well i think that the
computer's natural i think the computer
is bee pollen
yeah i think i think it's like honey i
think it's something that the the animal
makes well it's a um i think the
computer
is a uh the internet is the mycelium
the internet is the mycelium and the
computer is the the technology is the
fungal growth that's growing off of the
this network so when you see a computer
a pc you're actually looking at a little
fungal extrusion from the network that
we currently call the internet and it's
the more of these things that grow out
of of time then the more advanced it
becomes because the things seem to be
working together to make each of them
better yeah what conspiracy theories
do you believe
that are
important for people to think about
would you say um
kennedy was not killed by a lone gunman
with no connections to any other
situation government you know i believe
that jfk was removed from office
uh by a group of people that had
very
uh different interests but the question
of like deep state so these are powerful
people that are able now to dictate
uh through basically the threat of
violence what the
president's the surface powerful people
in our society yeah i mean i've no again
i'm not i i want another investigation
into 911 not because i think that george
bush pressed a button and made 911
happen but because we invaded the
country of iraq and then we uh you know
15 out of 19 hijackers were from saudi
arabia uh there was tons of stuff in the
911 report that didn't make sense to
anybody uh there's tons of stuff about
that day that i feel like we just don't
know
another theory is man there's there's a
theory that
i don't know the people are saying we
can't even see viruses they're too small
to even see like we could see bacteria
but even through an electron microscope
apparently we can't see viruses so
that's why when you go to uh google and
you
you you put in virus it's gonna show you
a bunch of cgi pictures like it's never
like an actual picture of a virus
in a cell
it's all cgi and when you do that you're
like [ __ ] so people um i don't know man
i don't know maybe like
how do we know what the [ __ ] is going on
how do we know if we can't see it
so i i've grown into a person that i
don't believe [ __ ] unless i could see it
or i could prove it for myself otherwise
you don't have to believe in [ __ ] you
could just say i don't know i don't
believe you but i don't know you don't
have to make a choice you know like oh
you either have to believe or not like i
don't know dude you know after so many
god how many lies does it take how many
more ebolas and all how many more
before you go okay enough at the [ __ ]
how many does it take another conspiracy
theory joke world has 44 000 subs on
youtube but only 6 000 followers on
instagram if you like this channel then
you'll definitely like what we're
posting on instagram we're featuring a
new comedian every single day go follow
link in bio we're sending everyone free
stickers this is what we were talking
about earlier so this is like i did just
to find and replace
in the uh in the book of john which is
my favorite
gospel in the bible it's the most
psychedelic one just trying to see what
happens if i plug in simulation theory
into the bible to see how it sounds i'll
just read it to you
in the beginning
was the code and the code was with the
programmer and the code was the
programmer he was with the programmer in
the beginning through him all things
were programmed without him nothing was
programmed that has been programmed in
him was life and that life was the
upgrade of all mankind the upgrade
shines in the darkness and the darkness
has not downloaded it the true upgrade
that upgrades everyone was coming into
the simulation he was in the simulation
and though the simulation was programmed
through him the simulation did not
recognize him he came to that which was
his own but his own did not receive him
yet to all who did receive him to those
who believed in his name he gave the
right to become children of the
programmer
it's so funny because you're looking at
like basically the ideas when you do the
translation
if this is a simulation
then the programmer
recognized that the ai inside the
simulation had reached a level of
sentience that it was actually
experiencing suffering the programmer
feeling this incredible rush of empathy
and compassion
put went into the simulation as an
avatar to try to create an upgrade using
his own body as the means to do it he
had his uh he and he allowed his own
simulation to destroy him as a sign of
love for the thing which he had
programmed jesus christ that's that's
what they called him yeah but that's the
idea
i would believe in simulation theory
before that yeah and that i believe that
i don't believe in flat earth but i
think there's something that is making
these guys think that yeah and like that
where there's smoke there's fire that
not that there is a flat plane or
anything like that but something isn't
adding up that they're going [ __ ]
crazy like and that could be simulation
theory like they went all the way down
they're going all the way down like they
like keep breaking down molecules more
and more and more to this one scientist
said he's found binary code like
ones and zeros like so deep into it you
keep slicing and dicing ones and zeros
that sounds like a computer program to
me so i don't [ __ ] know
i don't know i and here's the whole
thing nobody knows except for the
highest levels of [ __ ] nasa of what's
really going on if you sit there and go
nasa's told us everything that's true
all the time you're in denial
they've lied they've been caught lying a
lot i lie all the time so i know that
they're lying right you know
right it's human nature that we love
a billion dollars
i know this podcast is doing well in the
in tibetan buddhism it's called the
tulku system where they take children
and
they recognize stuff from past lives and
they'll like pick that and that's how
they know who like the next dalai lama
is going to be who is the next dalai
lama do we know well they don't know yet
because you have to die could it be your
kid
no way because
technically the way that would work
is
no because the the idea is the soul of
the awakened being when the body drops
chooses another
another portal another portal yeah and
then like there's all these signs and
and the signs lead it's very much like
the three wise men in the bible
leads people to the child and then they
bring the possessions that used to
belong to the former uh incarnation and
then but they mix it in with all this
other stuff wow and the baby like picks
the glasses and picks the thing and then
that confirms it's the baby and then
they take the baby it's a huge honor for
the parents but it's also very
controversial and the dalai lama has i
think kind of hinted that maybe that
system might be on the way out actually
why i like that system well yeah but
then you know there's the the criticism
i do too i think it's cool but the
criticism of is like you mean it's some
kind of like
theocracy where the priests essentially
steal a child and yeah and like
condition the child to yeah that's
that's the yeah there has to be a
sacrificial lamb right someone has to be
the thing i love your attitude about i
mean i think it's for the way it's been
explained to me is at least in those
times
in tibet it was just a huge
honor it would be essentially like
someone coming to you and saying that
you're a royalty or that you would have
a child and they're like oh your child's
royalty even they anoint you yeah you're
like um
it's as if like you have a child and
your kid becomes a kardashian like you
get anointed in american culture you
become holier than thou that's right
well yeah they're so close to having
little nanobots that swim around your
body and fix [ __ ] that's bad yep that's
right and they're peep they're people
who will tell you no it's never gonna
work they're never gonna reverse the
aging process they're they're so close
they're so close in so many ways there
was some new
thing that i tweeted really recently i
need to send the article i sent the
article to rhonda patrick but i need to
try to read it and decipher it myself
but in leafing through it essentially
they've found some new drug
that actually is showing to reverse the
aging process it lengthens telomeres
yeah and they're like this is the first
thing they've ever found that lengthens
telomeres and you know now they have to
do
these big studies on it figure out like
what is going on and what it what is but
it's essentially reversing the aging
process the aging process is a
biological thing and
it seems to me that
they
have at least the possibility of
figuring out some pretty incredible
aspects of it at least the possibility
dude i mean if you think about like if
you look at pictures
from the 1950s oh yeah of people your
age
right mm-hmm they didn't they were
pretty [ __ ] up like you know what i
mean like you you because you were you
had no idea
what
like
any kind like dietary standards you
thought cigarettes were good for you yup
there were no there was no environmental
regulations people were [ __ ] rubbing
radium cream on their balls you know
about that right like people like radium
used to get put into cosmetic products
the idea was that who's rubbing
cosmetics on their balls i would if
that's a government trying to kill
stupid people
that's what it is it's like not a bad
theory cream for your balls guys are
like i'm in
when do you when do your balls need
cream radioactive cream for your balls
the deep state is only a term for
unelected largely
power factions in washington dc
that outlive any presidential
administration these are people that
might work at the state department they
might work at the defense department
these are people that are not always
working officially in any government
capacity they might be private companies
they might be
military contractors they might be
people of boeing or raytheon or general
dynamics and they constitute
a group of people that trump kind of
called the swamp but trump had really no
interest in draining the swamp but it
was he articulated
these things and this is what it is you
have a lot of interested parties that
have
budgets that they want big budgets
everybody wants a budget in washington
whether you know what it is they want
money um and these are the people who
who really control press so this idea
that the president is the bln doll has
got to be smashed i'm i'm i have subtle
conspiracy theories
but they're but they're ones that are so
which ones which one i i'm even afraid
to say because people will go people get
offended when i say this which one which
one i think the government created aids
okay to kill black people and gays
i believe yeah i mean if you read the
book by bill cooper he talks about
basically that yeah they created a gay
agenda and there's nothing escaping well
there's a great degree gay gender and
then made aids to kill them off
um i wouldn't doubt it if i would if
they could do it they would do it i
wouldn't doubt it but when you hear
there was a guy on joe rogan's podcast
is dr doucheberg or something like that
one of the one callum was on
yeah where the guy was saying that aids
is just because of drug use
yes yeah yeah i listen to some of that
basically what he's saying is
aids is a condition you know aids is
like aids acquired immune deficiency
syndrome it means your immune system is
broke it means your engine is broke you
know so a lot of things can cause that
malnutrition
um
a whole shitload of viruses can can make
your immune system stop working so in
the case of aids
originally before was called aids it was
called grid gay related
uh
immune deficiency
it was a it was a gay disease because in
the 70s all the people that were showing
up with their immune system shot were
gay
so they were thinking [ __ ] and the gay
people were marching going [ __ ] why are
you guys ignoring us we [ __ ] all
these gay people are dying don't ignore
us we need funding we need to find out
what this f what the [ __ ] this is they
were making a lot of noise going why are
you guys calling it gay related immune
deficiency this is [ __ ] so
they decided to look into it they took
this now this is according to doucheberg
right they took um
a bunch of people that were dying of
aids and they all did tests on them and
they found out that uh 40 of them
had hiv
of all these people so just from that
report they just ran with hiv causes
aids but they didn't no one asked like
what about the people that didn't have
hiv why are they still dying of aids
they didn't give a [ __ ] about that they
just went full blown it's we're gonna
call it aids now we're not gonna call it
grid no more i think there's almost
something scary about vr it's not just
that it's cumbersome that you have to
put on gear and i had to put on a goggle
and then head side over that and you got
to hold these things it's not that
there's something that people are
uncomfortable with yeah like in
internally like they're introducing
their wife to the new man that's gonna
[ __ ] her wow
crazy that's crazy there's something
about vr that i think people secretly
know
like if it is as good as oculus and
htc
if it's as good as this now and no one
even knows about it
what is it going to be like in 50 years
indistinguishable from reality 100
yeah and 100 they will figure out a way
to put some heptactic
haptactic
and even better than that they're going
to figure out how to just charge certain
parts of your brain to experience
certain things like you might they might
be able to give you an artificial
feeling of heat you can look at your
life and see that in the continuum of
just your life you've you've basically
reincarnated if you look at you now
versus when you're a baby
you have reincarnated it's two
completely different forms right and
then also if you look at the phases of
your life you realize like oh [ __ ] it's
some like far back it might as well have
been
a different life it's a different house
it's right you know and
the older you get the more you realize
just how true that is and yet there
seems to be some kind of thread running
through it all right which is the
identity or the a sense of self or or
being something so
uh so that my the way i've been taught
about reincarnation is
that
it's more like a momentum thing it's
like
anything that has momentum in the
universe
uh that momentum in some way that energy
keeps going right but it gets
transferred into other things yeah
that's it i think that's just a natural
that's that's a super scientific
approach either way not all of the
patients that they did the tests on
according to doucheberg had hiv so what
the [ __ ] were they dying
how were they getting uh their immune
system shot so they never really got
into that they just said hiv boom so
what they ended up doing is when people
came up
with
an hiv positive
test result they would just get them on
azt which is a medication that they
stopped using for cancer patients
because it was killing them the azt was
killing them before the cancer so they
had a they had to shelve the azt but now
with this new aids they go let's bring
back azt and anybody that has
is test positive for hiv will give them
azt
and the people who are dying of azt not
aids some of them people who knows
according to douchebag where like we're
they were given azt because they had an
hiv-positive result when in reality they
probably would have lived if they would
have just figured out how to control the
hiv so what they ended up doing they
ended up realizing okay they knew that
you know let's let's let's stop azt oh
we got a new cocktail this is better and
it was safer so they stopped they
stopped azt for cancer treatment and
then they stopped it for aids or hiv
treatment and the the conspiracy theory
is that they're dying from the drugs not
from the hiv the drugs are [ __ ] them
that's why they had to pull a they don't
give azt out to aids patients some more
and they used to they used to do for
cancer too they don't do it anymore why
because it's too [ __ ] dangerous
[Music]
you